حتى الآن حتى الآن ، خلعت جزئيًا
رقبتي
كلا من رجلي ركبتي ومفصل الورك على
يدي وأعلى إصبع
قد خرج معظم جسدي في أوقات معينة ،
مما تسبب في إصابة الجهاز الهضمي
بالشلل و  لقد تم إطعامي من خلال
كل نوع من أنواع التغذية الأنبوبية التي من
المحتمل أن تكون
بالنسبة لي في الغالب هي ساقي التي
تعاني من ألم مزمن مستمر يزداد سوءًا
كلما أقف
في أسوأ حالاتي ، شعرت وكأنني كنت أعاني من كسر
الزجاج في
الوركين كثيرًا  بدأت أعضائي في
الانغلاق ، لم أستطع الشفاء من الإصابات التي
كان شعري يتساقط ،
لقد ولدنا بهذا ولن نتحرر منه أبدًا
بينما نحن على
كوكب الأرض
[موسيقى]
يمكنك التفكير في  النسيج الضام
كغراء يحافظ على تماسك جسمك ،
فهو أيضًا أكثر الأنسجة وفرة في
جسمك ، لذا إذا حدث خطأ ما
هنا ، يمكن أن تكون التأثيرات نظامية
ويمكن أن تكون أيضًا منهكة جدًا
للمريض بالطريقة التي تم وصفها لي هي أن
الجميع  يقام معا  r مع
الغراء الفائق والأشخاص المصابون بمتلازمة اللازانيا
معًا عن طريق مضغ
العلكة ، تشمل الأعراض النموذجية
عدم استقرار المفاصل وهشاشة أنسجة
الجهاز الهضمي وصعوبات
في تنظيم معدل ضربات القلب
وضغط الدم
[ضحك]
[الموسيقى]
الشيء الشائع داخل EDS هو أنه
يمكنك  تمر بمجموعة من
التشخيصات المختلفة ولا يوجد شيء يناسب حقًا
EDS المحمول الفائق الذي اعتاد اعتباره
نادرًا مع معدل انتشار يقدر بواحد من كل
خمسة آلاف ، لكن
الأبحاث الحديثة أظهرت أنه قد يكون
شائعًا مثل واحد من كل 500. حقيقة أنه
لا يوجد  يعني وجود علامة بيولوجية أو
جين حاليًا أن نسبة كبيرة
من الأطباء لا يعتقدون أن EDS هو
اضطراب حقيقي ولكن بصفتي شخصًا يعيش
مع EDS ، فأنا أعرف أن ما لدي هو حقيقي
وما يعاني منه المرضى الآخرون هو أيضًا
[موسيقى] حقيقية
تبدأ في  تشك في نفسك وبالتالي يمكن أن
يتسبب ذلك في الكثير من المعاناة النفسية من تلقاء نفسه
، حتى أنني حاولت الانتحار مرتين لأنني
شعرت أنه لا يوجد أمل حقيقي في
مستقبلي في هذه اللحظة  لقد تم تشخيصي بأنني
مصاب بالآخرين ، ربما كانت متلازمة داون
من أسعد لحظات حياتي على
الرغم من أنها حالة غير قابلة للشفاء في بعض الأحيان ،
إلا أنها تؤثر حقًا على كل شيء
لا يوجد عنصر في جسدي
يشبه الوظائف التي عادةً
ما أمضيتها خمس سنوات فقط.
مريض داخلي بالمستشفى وقد تقدمنا ​​بشكل أساسي من
خلال سلم التغذية الأنبوبية
كنت أحصل على درجتي الجامعية من
سرير المستشفى وألقي نظرة إلى الوراء وغالبًا
ما أتساءل كيف مررت بالفعل
بهذه الفترة الزمنية التي
أتغذى فيها بحليب خاص و  مضخة
وأنا متصل بهذه الـ 24 ساعة في اليوم
والتي من الواضح أن لها تأثيرًا هائلاً على
حياتك والعديد من الطرق المختلفة ليس
فقط جسديًا ولكن عاطفياً وعقليًا
اجتماعيًا ،
أنت تعرف أنك تحاول أن تشرح لشخص ما ،
نعم في بعض الأحيان ستفشل
مفاصلي على ما يرام  حسنًا ، ربما لا يمكننا وضع
هذه الخطط ، ربما لا يمكننا الحصول على بعض
هذه التجارب لأنني يجب أن
أعتني بجسدي أولاً
، وقد اضطررت إلى تغيير الكثير حول m  الحياة التي
كنت أعرضها عندما كنت مراهقًا
وكنت مغنيًا لفترة من الوقت ، وكان ذلك
ينطوي على الوقوف في مكان واحد في
الكعب وأدركت أن هذا شيء
يجب أن أتخلى عنه لأنني
تركت المدرسة منذ أكثر من  عام الآن بسبب
المضاعفات
الصحية وخلال ذلك الوقت كنت أركز حقًا
على مشاريع مناصرة EDS ،
لا يمكنك الفوز في هذه المعركة بمفردك عندما
يعمل جسمك ضدك ، فأنت بحاجة
إلى أن يعمل كل من حولك
معك كثيرًا منا  نجد طريقنا من
خلال هذا معًا
ولكن بالنسبة للجمهور من الصعب جدًا
فهمه وغالبًا لا
يؤمنون حقًا بأن التجربة حقيقية ،
فأنا أبدو شابًا وأبدو جيدًا بشكل عام لذا
قد يكون من الصعب جدًا التعامل معها
لأنك في الواقع  مثل التعامل
مع كل هذه الأشياء ولا يمكن لأحد أن يرى
أن القدرة على البحث في هذه
الحالة الغامضة هو شيء أستمتع به حقًا
، ومن ناحية أخرى ، فأنا مضطر إلى البحث عن
حالتي الخاصة والعثور على هذه الإجابات
بنفسي العلمية والطبية
يجب أن يكون المجال هو الرائد في محاولة مساعدة
المرضى الذين أرغب في التوقف عن فقدان الأشخاص
بسبب مضاعفات EDS لأن شخصًا ما
رآهم وصدقهم
[موسيقى]